foreign
[Music]
vertex AI we want to tell you about how
easy it is to scale AI from laptop to
Cloud by bringing Ray and vertex AI
together
I know there are many other interesting
and exciting sessions out there right
now but you're choosing to be here means
a lot to me we wouldn't be here without
you so thank you for that
I'm Chris product manager in vertex Ai
and this is hi everyone I'm Nina I'm a
software engineer at vertex AI
now uh how many of you guys have heard
of vertex AI raise your hand
keep your hand up there keep your hand
up there how many how many of you guys
have heard of Ray
wow very cool now keep your hand up keep
your hand up keep your hand up if you
are using Rey in production
okay very cool thank you very much I
hope to see a lot more hands next year
uh once we you know let our rayon vertex
out there in the world and you guys are
using it
well I'm excited to tell you about rayon
vertex AI my team's been working really
hard to show this to the world and I'm
very very happy to tell you about it
today
before we get into the details of Ray we
would like to provide you all with some
context first I will walk you through an
overview of Ray then Chris will go
through an overview of vertex lastly we
have a demo to show you exactly how it
works and how you can use rayon vartek's
AI
so what is Rey it sounds like a lot of
you here in the audience might know Ray
pretty well but for those of you who
don't I'll explain what Ray is all about
raise an open source unified distributed
computing platform for python workloads
commonly used for ML workloads Ray makes
it easy to create ml flows in a
distributed and parallelized way and
includes libraries to handle common
machine learning tasks
so let's define some Ray Basics and
terms we will use throughout this
presentation so that we're all on the
same page
I'm going to start with the ray cluster
array cluster is a set of nodes that run
Ray code array cluster can live on your
laptop on kubernetes or in the cloud
for our purposes today re clusters on
vertex will live on Google Cloud
let's move on to Ray core Ray core is an
open source python library for
distributed computing for right
applications
raycor helps paralyze and accelerate
python workloads
lastly we have Ray air error stands for
AI runtime rate air Builds on the
distributed computing of Ray core for AI
and ML workloads and provides tools for
machine learning that include data
processing training tuning reinforcement
learning and serving
so I'll talk a bit more about the ray
cluster which is made up of Ray nodes we
have two different types of nodes each
Ray cluster has to have one head node
and can have multiple worker nodes
worker nodes run rate code as well as
attributed scheduling and they each have
their own Object Store
array head node has the same functions
as the other nodes but also additionally
runs cluster management and Driver
processes for the worker nodes
moving on to Ray core as I mentioned
before Ray core is the low-level library
for building distributed systems Ray
core is made up of a few Primitives like
tasks and actors
data objects are stored in paths between
nodes in object references Ray core is
really what makes Rey fast and efficient
okay I think that's enough definitions
let's see what some Ray code looks like
as many of you know the cool thing about
Ray is that you can parallelize
computation easily for example what I'll
show you here is some image rotation
on the box to the right on top
we have a simple python function to read
an image from a file and rotate the
image we run this function on a list of
image files so the operation computes
sequentially naturally rotating a bunch
of images in sequence can take some time
moving to the bottom section here on the
right we're going to reify our code
we can do this with just a few small
changes to achieve paralyzed computation
the code will now run in a distributed
way on our Ray cluster across of all our
nodes in our cluster
in the blue you can see that we add Ray
remote in our code to indicate that this
function is now remanaged and we will
execute on the ray cluster remotely and
across different nodes
the function contents otherwise remain
pretty much the same
now we've talked about the right cluster
we've talked about Ray core and we've
seen how easy ray makes it to
parallelize code
let's talk some more about right air and
show you that Ray air makes efficient
machine learning code just as simple as
the python code we just saw
right air Builds on top of the
distribution power of Ray core and adds
simple libraries for raid data train
tuning and serving
Ray air code includes Integrations with
popular ml Frameworks like xgboost
tensorflow and pytorch I'm sure the
audience sees some icons they might
recognize in the left of this diagram
on the right we can see examples of
using Ray data to process a large data
set and pre-process data next we can see
an example of Ray train to train an XG
boost model we have Ray tuned for hyper
parameter tuning and last we have race
serve for deployment
all of these steps happen with just two
or three lines of code it's awesome how
simple Rey makes machine learning in our
demo we're going to show you how a
similar flow runs on vertex AI now that
we've talked about Ray I'll pass it over
to Chris to talk more about vertex
thanks
I want to tell you a little bit about
vertex Ai and gcp's Mission and how we
fit into it
you might have seen this before gcp's
mission is to help
accelerate organization's ability to
digitally transform its business and one
of the best ways I've seen customers
achieve this goal is to deploy AI in a
real world real world settings and
enabling their businesses and their
people to become AI creators
from infrastructure to train and tune
your models all the way up to trained AI
agents ready-made for Enterprise use
cases vertex AI has all the toolings you
need
now I want to take our Focus to the AI
platform and then look it a little bit
closer
AI platform includes the ml platform
that provides the end-to-end managed ml
Ops experience
and in the Green Building on top of that
an integrated gen AI experience through
model garden and gen AI Studio
and we are continuing to build out and
investing in this platform in four key
areas the data to AI experience to
accelerate time to value and the whole
managed end-to-end mlaps experience to
govern AI
scalable and open infrastructure and
lastly provide state-of-the-art AI to
help customers innovate
no matter where you are in your AI
Journey you can find something useful in
vertex AI
now to put money where the mouth is
about scalable and open infrastructure
we're investing not just in open open
source models but also integrating with
popular open source Frameworks like
right
so that you as AI creators can build and
scale faster in your AI Journey
now before we go into talking about rate
on vertex AI I have a I have a little
confession to make in my LinkedIn it
says I have a master's degree in CS but
I gotta say I barely I
just passed
because of this
evil core is called intro to OS
operating systems
build this Quest
twice I had to drop it out
homework that you do is you have to
write parallelization code distributed
computing framework in C
and I could not figure this out
now
this is what I knew that I could never
be an engineer or be a data scientist
like you guys
still don't know how to write this in CE
but I I can do this in Rey so even
a dumb PM like me can paralyze my code
how much more can you guys do with Ray
right
and we're bringing this together uh with
Ray and vertex and power vertex and
ready together so that we are providing
these capabilities to you
and I'm so excited to announce publicly
today uh the vertex is committed to
support Ray as a first class product
rayon vertex AI is three E's easy to use
uh engineer for AI creators and
Enterprise ready and my team created
this product with Ray users in mind so
that any existing Ray code can be used
with just one line or minimal change
and you can see it on the top left and
the radar in it and all you have to do
is provide a Vertex rate Target and then
you can connect and talk to the array on
vertex AI cluster
now let's take a quick comparison
between the setup process of the OSS Ray
and Ray on vertexa
like any cluster or rate cluster setup
you gotta do the basics in the green box
that's a non-negotiable you have to set
up your networking IAM and all the info
stuff that you have to do now you still
have to do additional steps with by
providing resources like VMS and disks
and start Ray head and work on workers
in the notes set up utility functions
like Jupiter lab and OSS dashboard
connect to the logging monitoring and be
able to collect all that information
and lastly control your
infrastructure costs through providing
turndown commands and scheduling
and it's all finding good if you want to
do all that work that's more power to
you
with rayon vertex AI though you do not
have to worry about any of that stuff
because we take care of all of these
things for you when you create random
vertex cluster through our python SDK or
UI it already provides an integrated
experience with collab Cloud logging
Cloud monitoring and we even take care
of the idle shutdowns and near zero
scaling so that you don't have to worry
about it
we made this so that you can focus on
the most important aspect of your work
which is to be an AI creator
now
they say picture is worth a thousand
words and
I think a demo is worth a thousand
presentations so we got three demos for
you so I think this demo is worth like 3
000 presentations
so Nina is going to show you how to
create the ray the array cluster through
the UI BQ integration and lastly a
simple end-to-end XG boost example
all right then what time let me uh turn
it over to you Nina thank you Chris we
think that rayon vertex AI combines the
ease and simplicity a vertex of Rey with
the managed capabilities of vertex I'm
gonna head over to our demo now
I'm going to show you three demos
um the first one will be creating a ray
cluster the second one will be showing
you our native bigquery integration and
the third one is going to be a full
end-to-end machine learning flow
so let's start out with creating array
cluster so I'm in our Google Cloud
console I'm already on the rayon vertex
AI page but if you scroll down to manage
you can also get to this rayon vertex AI
page from here I can go ahead and create
array cluster
setting up a ray cluster is really
simple it only takes three steps the
first one is selecting a name for our
cluster and a region
so I'll go ahead and do that
the second is choosing machine types for
the head node and worker nodes that I
described earlier in the right cluster
so here I can choose from different
machine types and I can also choose gpus
and accelerators if I want here's a list
of some accelerator types
you can also choose disk types
now our worker pools correspond to the
rayworker nodes that I had discussed
before so here I can also choose machine
types and accelerators and disks as well
the replica count corresponds to how
many machines we have of each machine
type so if I had three I would have
three worker nodes in this worker pool
I'll continue on to the third and final
step which is configuring security and
networking I can choose a service
account if I want and I can also connect
to a network
so I'll go ahead and create this cluster
so while that's
provisioning here this can take a few
minutes so I'm going to show you some of
the running clusters we already have
showing you the specs of this cluster we
can see that we have
Ray version 2.4 and python version 310.
we also have this machine type that I've
selected and in my work group pools for
this cluster I selected a V100
accelerator
back on the main page you can also see a
button open in colab Enterprise
we've integrated with collab Enterprise
to make interacting with your ray
cluster really easy
we have a collab runtime template that
provides array version python version
and you're not working already set up
for you
here I can show you a runtime template
you can see we have a bunch of them set
up here with our networking our python
version
and our Ray version here on the right
from these runtime templates you can go
ahead and create a notebook from scratch
but for the purpose of the demo we've
already pre-loaded a notebook for you
okay so let's get into it now that I've
created a right cluster I want to go
ahead and connect to it so first I'm
going to set up
array and our vertex AI SDK so I just
ran that cell initialized our vertex AI
SDK as well now I'm going to check that
Ray's installed and our Ray version is
2.4
this is the fun part we're going to
actually connect to our rate cluster
just using one line right knit and we'll
add in the address of that cluster we
just created
you can see it's connected
[Music]
off the ray version of the right cluster
and a link to the open source Ray
dashboard this dashboard gives us more
information about what's going on in
your cluster what jobs are running how
many resources are used we also provide
a link to our interactive terminal URI
and you can log on to SSH into array
head node to do some debugging
moving on now that we're connected we
can actually run some really simple
array code on this cluster
so here I have a function to square some
integers and I'm going to do it in four
parallel Square tasks
um I'll X Out the spot and you can see
the output here 0 1 4 9.
we also have a second simple function
just to do a Hello World and combine
that with the squaring function
that was the first part of our demo from
this part you can see how easy it is to
create a right cluster on the UI
connect to it on our collab and run some
simple code
now we'll get into the second part of
our demo
I'm going to show you how we have
integrated bigquery seamlessly with Ray
data
I'm going to run some setup here then I
will get into raid data bigquery read so
what we do here is you can seamlessly
read data from bigquery into array data
table
Ray data needs a data source typically
open source Ray users have to use
existing data source like mongodb S3 or
a CSV file
we read seamlessly from bigquery and we
also incorporate the parallelism part of
array data in our integration as well
this will take a few seconds to run here
okay awesome it seems like it done and
it only took 13 seconds
next we'll get into Ray data transform
we also support Ray data transforming
here and you can see that the mapping
and shuffling functions of Ray data are
also supported
last we will get into our Ray data
bigquery right we can write back to
bigquery people might want to do this
after doing batch prediction or doing
some data transformation
this also will take a few seconds it's
writing 569 rows here
okay that was pretty quick
um and that's the second part of our
demo moving on to the last and final
part here I'm going to show you a
similar example to the ray air
end-to-end machine learning flow we
showed you before I think this is really
valuable because it shows you that you
can use rate air machine learning code
with very minimal modifications on rayon
vertex AI which makes it very easy to
scale
so I already showed you how I
um loaded data from bigquery transformed
it and wrote it back now I'm going to
use that same data source to prepare
some data sets for our training of our
model
so I'll run this this sets up a training
data set a validation data set and lost
a test data set
then I'm going to use a provided
preprocessor from the ray data Library
I'll add in a standard scalar here and
that'll normalize my data
now that we've done our setup we can
actually go ahead and train our model so
we're going to train a binary classifier
here that has 30 input features in the
input data this is an XG boost model and
this code was taken from the ray open
source documentations you can see once
again how it seamlessly runs on vertex
this will I think take maybe 15 seconds
you can see it's going through
um
some training here
scrolling up just a bit we included some
actually boost specific parameters our
data sets and our preprocessor
seems like this has finished already and
we've trained our model
next up is Ray tune we can use retune
for hyper parameter tuning Our model
so I'll run these cells
this one takes a little bit longer to
run so I'm going to show you an output
from a cluster we ran earlier today
foreign
you can see down here that we ran hyper
parameter tuning on five trials and
scrolling down
we have five trials here
with different train log loss and valid
law gloss
and once our hyper parameter tuning is
complete we're going to choose the best
result and use that for our final model
next we're going to upload the model to
the vertex model registry
um and register the model within vertex
AI
and this step can take some time so once
again I'm just going to show the output
but once the model is in
the model registry we can just deploy it
to an end point and then use it for live
predictions
so in this output you can see that we're
creating an endpoint
and it takes a few minutes and then once
our endpoint is ready you can see this
endpoint object now this endpoint object
is ready to be used for live predictions
so I'm going to pass in some test data
you can see this is what the data set
looks like with 30 input features
then I'm going to pass in a prediction
request
and then our endpoint comes out with all
of these predictions
so you can see that this last demo
showed the full machine learning
end-to-end flow from these three demos
you've seen how we can create array
cluster really easily how we can
integrate with bigquery and Ray data and
lastly how we can run that full machine
learning end-to-end flow I'll hand it
back to Chris
awesome awesome thank you Nina
it's not uh easy giving live demos
should a wonderful Jeff thank you so
much I really really appreciate that
all right so as you saw rayon vertex AI
is easy to get started and just get your
code running we have many Native
Integrations that you saw from this code
with vertex and gcp products and many
more are on the way now some of you may
be wondering how can I use this in my
context in my company so let me tell you
one example of customers that we talked
earlier this year that we got to show
ram versus Ai Ai and you know they were
really excited about it and let me give
you some context here so
how many of you heard of Dometic by any
chance
there we go we got one person thank you
very much so the medic what they do is
they manage
customer supply chain and they have they
have robots that you see that are
running around in the warehouses
managing inventory doing pickpacking
processes and whatnot and they're doing
something really cool
uh what they're doing with
with Ray is it their training and
reinforcement learning agent to be
deployed in each of these robots to help
their processes
and when I was showing them our roadmap
where we're going at rayon vertex AI uh
the team really found it exciting and
they're excited to use and are using uh
us to scale up and to manage different
RL agents for their use case so that
they can serve their customers and help
them deliver more value
all right so sum up our time together I
want to leave you with this so if you
remember nothing
nothing else from this session I want to
help you remember threes threes right
easy to use
engineer for AI creators Enterprise
ready is it easy to use use engineer for
AI creators and Enterprise ready as you
saw through with Nina's demo using Ray
to deliver end-to-end AOS
now it's even easier with vertex AI
taking care of some of the setup burdens
for you
so that you as AI creators can focus on
what matters the most
lastly we want to make sure your most
important work runs on a secure scalable
and reliable platform and vertex AI is
the place to do so
preview version of rayon vertex AI will
be available in September we got some
exciting Integrations that that are
happening that I can't talk about just
yet but you'll find out through the uh
the preview refresh in q1 and ga next
year
please check out amazing Karthik and
then shot Karthik ranger please raise
your hand the combo session and AIML 124
please go to my boss and my boss's
Boston session so that maybe uh maybe
they'll give me some bonus points for
getting more people in there
and please come check us out at the
Showcase Booth my good friends Ivan
Mikhail and sujit will show to show how
to tune open llama with pi torch but
unlike ninjas a llama 2 demo I think
this llama has a lot of drama be because
it's using Ram vertex Ai and I think
that's a big deal well thanks for the
opportunity for us to tell you about Ram
vertex Ai and see you at the collab
session and Showcase Theater
foreign